- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to further build our intuition
for multiplying decimals.
So let's say that we wanted to figure out
what eight times seven tenths is.
Pause this video and see if you can figure
this out on your own.
All right, now there's several ways
that we could approach what
eight times seven tenths is.
We could view this as eight times,
and we could write seven
tenths as a fraction.
So we can re-express this as seven tenths,
seven over 10 is the same thing as 0.7.
And we already know how
to multiply fractions,
you could view this as being equal to,
eight is the same thing as
eight over one or eight wholes,
I guess you could say,
times seven over 10,
times seven tenths, which
is going to be equal to,
if we multiply our numerator,
we're going to get 56.
And if we multiply our
denominators, we get tenths.
And that makes sense.
If I have eight times seven
tenths, I end up with 56 tenths.
Now 56 tenths can also be written as,
this is the same thing
as 50, plus six over 10,
which is the same thing as
50 over 10, plus six over 10.
And so this is the same thing
as, this is five wholes,
so five and six tenths,
five and six tenths,
which we can write as five
and six tenths, or 5.6.
And it's always good to do a
little bit of a reality check,
whenever you get an answer when
you're multiplying decimals.
Say, okay, seven tenths is
a little bit less than one.
So we would expect this product,
if we're multiplying eight times something
a little bit less than one,
we would expect the product to be
a little bit less than eight.
So 5.6 makes sense.
If for some reason we got,
the we you computed something
and you were to get 60,
you say, well, that doesn't make sense,
I should get a value less than eight.
And similarly, if you somehow got a value
or product of like one, you're like, well,
that's a lot less than
eight, I should get something
that is seven tenths of eight.
Now, another way that
you could approach this
is you could view this as the
same thing as eight times,
and once again, I'm just gonna write this
in a different way, eight times seven,
eight times seven tenths.
So, if you have eight
times seven of something,
what is that going to be equal to?
Well, eight times seven, that's 56.
So you're going to be,
this is going to be equal to 56 tenths,
56 tenths.
And one way to think about 56 tenths,
56 tenths is the same thing as 50 tenths,
50, let me color code that differently.
So this is going to be the
same thing as 50 tenths,
50 tenths, plus six tenths,
plus the six tenths, get
right tenths, six tenths,
and 50 tenths is the
same thing as five ones.
So five ones, and six tenths,
which is exactly what we have here,
five ones, and six tenths.
Let's do another example,
that's a little bit more involved.
So let's say that we want to figure out,
we want to figure out what is
three times 0.87.
Pause this video and
try to figure that out.
Well, once again, there's
many ways to approach it.
But we could just start with
the way that we just looked at.
We could say, hey, this is
the same thing as three times,
and we can re-express this as,
this is the same thing as 87 hundredths.
87 hundredths,
and so if I have three
times 87 of something,
what am I going to be left with?
Well, this is going to be equal
to some number of hundredths,
and to figure out that, we just figure out
what's three times 87?
So 87 times three,
seven times three is 21,
we regroup that two, becomes two 10s.
And then eight times three is 24.
And that's really 24 10s
plus those other two 10s,
so we get 26 10s, which is
the same thing as 206 10s,
but it's gonna be 261.
So the three times 87 of
something is going to be 261
of that something, and this
case something is hundredths.
So this is 261 hundredths.
So how do we express this as a decimal?
Well, there's a couple of
ways that you can approach it.
You can think about is
this is the ones place,
this is the tenths place,
this is the hundredths place.
And so very clearly, 100th here
would be one in the hundredths place.
If you have 60 hundredths, which
is what the six represents,
60 hundredths is the
same thing as six tenths.
And then last but not least,
if you have 200 hundredths,
that's the same thing as two wholes.
Another way to think about it is,
you go to the hundredths place,
and then you start from
there, but you write out 261,
one, the 60 hundredths, and
then the 200 hundredths,
and you get 2.61.
Now another way that you
could have approached this,
and we saw this in the last example,
is you could say hey, this
is going to be the same thing
as three times at 87 hundredths.
(mumbles) These are all equivalent,
but hopefully one of these,
or more than one of these register
with you of what's really going on.
Well, this is going to be the
same thing as three wholes,
times 87 hundredths, 87 hundredths.
And so this is going to be
equal to, in the numerator,
we have three times 87.
Three times 87 hundredths,
one times 100 is 100.
well, we already know
what three times 87 is, this
is equal to 261 hundredths.
And you can see 100
goes into 261, two times
and you're left with 61 hundredths.
So these are all
equivalent representations.
And just reminder, so it's
always good to estimate.
And so what you have is you
have three times something
that's a little bit less than one.
So you would expect a value,
a little bit less than three.
And so 2.61 also meets that sniff test,
that this seems about right.
If for some reason you got 26 or 261,
that would be way off or
even if you got 0.261,
that would also feel way off.
So hopefully this is helpful.